Socotra is a unique island. An island that
remained isolated from the world until 2002, when
a small airport was built for the first time. With
its landscape, Socotra has stimulated over the
centuries the imagination of many travelers with
its peculiar umbrella-shaped trees: the Socotra
Dragon Trees. According to one of the old local
stories, the first seed of Dragon Tree, sprouted
in the exact spot where two brothers - Darsa and
Samha - chose to fight to death. A story that
kinda reminds us of Cain and Abel in the Bible.
In Arabic, this peculiar kind of tree is known as
the blood of the two brothers. For centuries the
islanders have used the reddish sap of this tree
as an ointment with magical properties, and it
is no coincidence that the dragon tree has become
over time the most recognizable symbol of Socotra
Island, an island endowed with a biodiversity more
alien than terrestrial. Socotra is an island
blessed with more than 700 endemic species of
flora and fauna, unique in their kind, and thanks
to which in 2008 UNESCO appointed the island a
World Heritage Site to be preserved and protected.
Nature is the true master of Socotra, a beauty
that has always inspired me to get interested
in the events of this island, so much so that
I hope one day to be able to visit it, although
I don't see that as feasible thing at the moment
bizarre plants, untouched and tremendously
fascinating shores, and unspoiled highlands.
For many, Socotra is a piece of paradise, but for
others it's just a barren land to be exploited.
Located in the Indian Ocean, in a position
which makes it geographically part of the
African continent, Socotra is closer to Somalia
than to Yemen: from the Somali coast, the island
is about two hundred and forty kilomiters away,
while from the Yemeni coast it is more than
double. This distance has contributed in large
part to the isolation and sense of mystery that
Arab, Persian and African sailors felt about
such a remote island. The archipelago of Socotra
is formed by three other small strips
of land, Abd Al Kuri, Darsa and Samha.
The 60,000 inhabitants living on the island
have always relied on fishing and on the
cultivation of date palms, and despite belonging
politically to Yemen since 1990, the islanders,
half Shiite and half Sunni, boast their own
culture and a different language, Socotri,
a Semitic language even older than Arabic and
whose origin is still an arcane mystery. this
day Socotra finds itself embroiled in a civil war
that has been ravaging Yemen since 2015. Socotra
became the epicenter of a power struggle between
the Houthi rebels and the Central Government,
but it became also the place of another secondary
conflict: the one between the United Arab Emirates
and the Yemeni government of Mansur Hadi. The
situation in Yemen has been tragic for over
six years, to be exact since Hadi was forced by
Shiite rebels belonging to the Ansar Allah group,
better known as Houthi, to resign from its
presidency, abandon the capital San'a and leave
it under the control of the rebels. The war in
Yemen is better known as a proxy war, a conflict
where the real actors are quite different from
those facing each other on the battlefield: under
the surface Yemen is actually disputed on one side
by the Saudis, supported by the rest of the gulf
countries and the US, which approved the official
government of Hadi. On the other side there's
Iran, which in historical contrast to the Saudi
monarchy, supports the rebellion of the Houthis,
seeing it as a possibility to expand its sphere of
influence directly in the Arabian peninsula. We'll
talk more about the war in Yemen in another video.
Known as "the jewel of the Gulf of Aden," Socotra
is situated off the Horn of Africa, overlooking
the Bab el-Mandeb Strait, which connects the
Red Sea to both the Gulf of Aden and the Arabian
Sea. The attentions surrounding Socotra are many:
Every day, more than three million oil barrels
travel from the Persian Gulf to the Indian Ocean.
Ships on this route travel west across the Arabian
Sea into the Gulf of Aden, then turn north,
entering the Red Sea through the narrow Bab
el-Mandeb passage before going up to the Suez
Canal. The Socotra Archipelago occupies a critical
position on the route to Bab el-Mandeb. Socotra's
central location also makes it an ideal launching
point for interdicting pirates and smugglers.
It protects the trade routes and all the fishing
communities along the Horn of Africa and the
southern coast of Yemen. From Iran to Somalia,
and from Eritrea to Qatar and India, for years,
international and regional powers have struggled
to establish bases around the Horn of Africa. To
have a strategic advantage over all these nations
is the United Arab Emirates, which since 2018,
has maintained a military presence on the island
to support the STC, the Southern Transitional
Council, an entity whose purpose is to achieve
the separation of South Yemen from the rest of the
nation. The Emirates' presence has only increased
divisions on the island: Socotra's governor,
Ramzi Mahrous, has always rejected the presence
of the STC, being in his eyes a clear threat to
his figure; on the other hand, however, many
islander are polarized on the choice to adopt:
to support the Transitional Council of the
South, and therefore the Arab Emirates,
or to refuse the interference of a foreign country
in the island's affairs. Separated from food and
fuel supplies since the outbreak of the War, the
Island was left at the mercy of its own fate:
The absence of Houthis on the island couldn't
grant a casus belli to intervene militarily,
and so the Emirates - with the initial support
of the Saudis - used the excuse of humanitarian
aid to set foot on the island and secure
the support of part of the population.
They found the opportunity in 2015, when in the
space of a few days Socotra ended up being hit by
two tropical cyclones that brought destruction
and further misery to the population that had
already been living on less than a dollar a day
for decades. Masquerading it as a large-scale
humanitarian intervention by the Red Crescent,
Abu Dhabi deployed over 5,000 troops to the
island without the coordination or approval of
either the Yemeni government or the governor
of Socotra. In 2018, the United Arab Emirates
under the guise of training local Yemeni forces
in Socotra reportedly began to weave a series of
personal interests on the island: First of all,
they did it to strengthen military connections
with all their bases along the Horn of Africa,
such as the Berbera base in Somaliland, the Assab
naval base in Eritrea, and other military barracks
in Puntland, in Somalia. From a strategic point of
view, Socotra provides a vital link between these
regions and would allow the Emirate navy
to conduct important security operations:
in terms of contrasting piracy, the island has
long been a docking base for many of the Somali
pirates who operate far and wide along the
Horn of Africa as far as the Omani coast. A
stable presence would also allow the emirates, and
implicitly the Saudis, to keep out Iranian boats
that transport arms and supplies to the Houthi
rebels. In a proxy war against Iran, all of this
would strengthen Saudi Arabia. In this conflict,
Socotra would serve as an excellent support base
from which to launch rockets against the Houthis
in Yemen. The fact that the Emirates use Socotra
as a military base is still a matter of debate,
given the logistical problems of the island,
such as those dictated by the climate and
monsoons which, for six months of the year,
make operations in the area very difficult. The
interest of the United Arab Emirates in Socotra
has been interpreted as a challenge by Saudi
Arabia: by occupying the island, the Emirates
are trying to block the expansion and the regional
domination of Saudi Arabia in the entire region,
consolidating their presence in the triangle
that at its vertices touches Aden, Socotra and
the small island of Barim. And so, the reasons
that led Abu Dhabi to be guaranteed a 99-year
concession by President Hadi would be mainly
economic: Controlling Socotra would mean acquiring
a large slice of the monopoly in the traffic of
oil and gas that passes through Bab El Mandeb,
a move made in total autonomy and in contrast with
both Iran and Saudi Arabia. With the occupation
of Socotra, the Emirates would also be able to
acquire kilometers and kilometers of Indian Ocean,
through the strengthening of an Exclusive Economic
Zone in the territorial waters around the island.
For the Saudis, the Emirates are an alliance of
convenience. It's not by chance that the Emirates
are planning to annex Socotra by organizing a
referendum in order to make the islanders decide
whether to become officially part of the Emirates
or remain at the mercy of the uncertainty of war;
Feeling neglected by Hadi's central government,
the Socotrians had no choice but to welcome
Abu Dhabi's investments. The Emiratis have not
only built basic infrastructure, such as roads,
hospitals and schools, but they have also paid the
salaries of doctors, policemen and bureaucrats,
creating new opportunities, for a total of 5,000
new jobs. After 2 weeks in May 2018, the Emirati
troops abandoned the island, they got replaced by
Saudi troops but they still left behind officials
who are working for the Khalifa Foundation of
Abu Dhabi, a government-sponsored charity. For
Governor Mahrus, however, such charitable
organizations would conceal a more devious
objective: that is, to buy the loyalty of Socotra
residents, and allow UAE traders and investors to
conduct business on the island under their cover.
These organizations would facilitate the purchase
of land to wealthy Emiratis, despite the presence
of a government decree prohibiting the sale of
any land on the island. Many of these lots would
belong to protected coastal areas, in which the
construction of buildings, and changes to the
landscape are prohibited; yet, when buying land
with prices ranging from hundreds of thousands to
tens of millions of dollars, Emiratis have never
hidden their goals of building private houses and
tourist resorts. Emirates, and no longer Yemen,
seem to have become the headquarter of the island:
witness to this are the Emirates companies which
have weekly flights between Hadiboh, capital of
Socotra, and Abu Dhabi. The Emiratis are also
aware that Socotra may become a great catalyst for
tourism. Before the civil war, the island operated
a particular kind of ecotourism, respectful of the
environment, which granted a small number of visas
per year, especially to scientists to facilitate
their study of Socotra's ecosystem. All of this
may disappear with the Emirati occupation and
with their plans to favor luxury resorts all
over the island, just like they already did
in Dubai with their artificial archipelagos.
I might say that the objective is very simple:
to transform Socotra into a Dubai 2.0. To do so,
Socotra's deputy governor for environment
and development, Abduljameel Mohammed,
as well as Emirati companies have reportedly
already begun excavating several sections of
the island's national park in preparation for
a series of five-star resorts. Leaving aside
the contradictions of seeing five-star hotels in
villages still destroyed by monsoons and poverty,
all this has raised a lot of criticism in the
island: as reported by local sources, the Emirates
didn't obtain any permission from Yemen to start
their construction projects. In addition to this,
some reports highlighted that several endangered
species - both plants and animals - have been
taken from the island and resettled in the
Emirates. Many Socotrians saw this move as not
only a violation of the island's identity but
also as an offense against their environment,
something made possible by the position of
supremacy enjoyed by Emirati officials there.
The possibility of the island being used
as a new destination for vacationing
has raised concerns related to pollution
of a fragile ecosystem. And maybe this is
the saddest element of the story. Also, the
fact that the Emirates, several months later,
sent troops on the Island, again
doesn't bode well.
Abu Dhabi does not seem willing to leave the bone
- which is metaphorically the island - in the
hands of the Saudis. Because this is what it’s all
about: a bone, an island that is at risk of being
stripped of all its beauty for mere geopolitical
and economic plots. Yemeni journalist Mohammed
al-Rumim earlier this year said, "The UAE is not
a friend of Socotra. They're only interested in
colonizing it." The Emirates have always denied
the accusations of neo-colonialism. But what seems
more and more certain is that the Emirates
intend to keep their presence on the island
with or without Yemeni approval. On the one hand
this allows the Emirates to avoid open conflicts
with the Arabs and other competitors, such as
Israel which seems to have an intelligence base
on the island, on the other hand it relegates the
islanders to pawns in a geopolitical chess game
whose outcome could prove catastrophic
for their traditional lifestyle
and for the island they call home. Only time will
tell which side will prevail. They say that time
is a gentleman. I have serious doubts that it
will be so in this case. Thanks to everyone
for listening and keeping me company until
the end. See you in the next video. Bye.